okay so then I'll give you my version of
a marginalized story voice okay lemma
versus a middle class one marginalized
one would be a little girl wants to go
to a birthday party but her the friends
in the neighborhood the mothers know
that her mom cleans houses right and
they don't she's nice but we don't
really know or dear I'm so sorry and the
middle class one is someone's applying
for colleges but it turns out most of
her friends are getting accepted to
another one and she's not sure if her
GPA is good enough to get into that one
okay and so she's like worried that oh
my gosh I'm gonna lose all my my good
high school friends and what's gonna
happen am i standing in that sort of
group got it so these are like seeds of
a story right to to to exist
okay so tell me what's your question my
question is are the stakes higher for
the author with the marginalized voice
where that means non inclusion into a
group whereas the other one the middle
class one is more worried about just
maybe losing sort of footing and maybe
losing touch it are the stakes higher
for one versus yeah I think that I I
don't think of stakes I mean gosh I I
don't know how to answer that question
because I don't think the the stakes are
about the the the actual situation the
stakes are really about the ability for
the writer to convey a sense of you know
urgency or anxiety in other words yeah
III but that one that's not we're not
really talking about dilemma we're just
talking about stakes the stakes should
always be life and death in every story
they're always life and death if Jan
Brady doesn't get a date with tad
Hamilton she will absolutely die stakes
are always life and death hmm if they're
anything less than life and death we
don't care at all we don't care at all
god okay you know so so but but if you
want to talk about dilemma there are two
ingredients to a dilemma as I see so
dilemmas a
a problem that can't be solved without
creating another problem and when you
connect to your dilemma you're
connecting to the aliveness in your
story there are two ingredients to a
dilemma a powerful want a powerful
desire okay and a false belief a
misperception of myself or the world
okay and so when Sally loves me then
I'll be complete
okay now we're good that's the big
that's the beginning of the story I got
to get Sally to love me in order to be
complete do you see a powerful desire if
Sally doesn't love me my life will be
unimaginable and the false belief is
that Sally will complete me at some
point so we've got a powerful desire
remember that story structures desire
surrender transformation we've got a
surrender I mean I'm going to have to
let go of the meaning I make out of my
goal as long as I believe that Sally's
love completes me
I will forever be in bondage to Sally or
my idea of Sally's love because the
stand and the audience of the reader is
going to be disappointed if all that
happens at the end of the story is that
Sally loves me that's gonna be a really
does
if Jimmy Stewart left Bedford Falls at
the end of It's a Wonderful Life we
would be disappointed because that's not
what the story's about story isn't about
the plot is about will Sally love me the
theme is about completeness what does it
mean to be complete oh it doesn't mean
completeness comes from outside of
ourselves it comes from within okay so
that's that's a dilemma the dilemma is
what is it the theme is completeness you
know if you're doing a story about
justice let's say I'm in prison and or
freedom let's say let's say this is a
story about what does it mean to be free
so if I'm in prison and I want to I want
to be free I might believe at the
beginning of the story that when I
escape then I'll be free okay and that's
that's the dilemma that's the dramatic
question and then through the story
I might actually succeed in escaping and
discover that I'm still not free
that could be the dark night of the soul
let's say I let's say I escaped with
another buddy and were shackled and we
and we get away and then he trips and
you know twists his ankle and now I've
got to decide you know I really want to
be free but now now I got to take a
blunt instrument and kill my buddy and
you know what I mean and get a okay and
now now am I free you know what I'm
saying and they're chasing after me and
and so in my in my attempt to become
free in your protagonist attempt to get
what he or she wants they move
increasingly away from their desire okay
so my attempt to be free moves me
further away from freedom leading to the
end of act 2 where I have to let go of
the meaning I made out of my goal
ie when I escaped prison then I'll be
free end of Act two I discover that free
true freedom comes from within and I
might discover at the end of the story
that freedom might involve going back to
prison taking responsibility for my
crime okay and so that's the shift in
perception so that would be so desire I
want to be free surrender I have to let
go of the meaning of my false belief of
what freedom means and transformation I
have a new understanding of freedom I
think you'd use the social network in
another video I watched oh you want to
use that as an analogy as well because I
found that interesting oh oh yeah yeah I
think I got that was a long time ago so
the dilemma of the social network is is
that is the tension between integrity
and ambition okay so if I'm really
ambitious and I want to make a billion
dollars I I you know it's the same kind
of thing I set out on this this this
quest but did I steal this idea from
these two gorgeous twins and yeah and
and and so and I and that's what that's
what the social network explores every
single scene examines the dilemma of
integrity of integrity versus ambition
okay and so he's driven by his ambition
what do I want I want to succeed what do
I need I need to do the right thing okay
and I think I think it's kind of an
ambiguous ending but it leaves us with
that question you know does the end
satisfy the means or doesn't yeah
something like that
you